I couldn't make the K18 hair mask at home,
so obviously I had to go get the K18 repair service.
My hair was in desperate need of some love.
I've been using K18 for a couple years now.
Ever since I started straightening my hair a bunch,
it was time for the treatment.
My stylist started off with promised and got it all through my hair.
She made sure to detangle it and then moved on to the leave in mask.
She used about one to two pumps.
She started blowing out my hair.
We worked in sections to make sure that everything was really smooth.
I love how shiny my hair is even after just the blow dry.
She went in with the K18 oil,
only used one drop, worked it through my hair,
and then straightened my hair.
I love how healthy and shiny my hair looks every time I use K18.